hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
microbial
quality control in manufacturing of
medicinal products i'm alexis cross of
labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labberts
and sponsored by sartorius for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
sartorius.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box located on the left
side of your screen and click on the
send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
ziva abraham ceo and principal
microbiology consultant
at microwright incorporated for a
complete biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
ziva you may now begin your presentation
thank you alexis for the introduction
and
thank you everybody for attending and
thank you sartorius
we will be covering i will not talk
about myself
except for one sentence i'm a passionate
microbiologist med school dropout
pharmaceutical microbiologist clinical
scientist and a mycologist
and my passion is to
make people understand
that microbiology is very important
and it starts from facility design to
product release
this is evident this is evident every
year
from the 483 observations
let's just summarize the 483
observations
here
i'm going to make the slides a little
bigger so everybody can see
look at this procedures applicable to
quality units shall be
in writing and shall be followed
investigations right of discrepancies
most people don't understand that
investigations
is not an exercise it is to understand
what happened
why happen and uh how to remediate it
but the most important part is how does
it
affect the patient it's all about the
patient
possibility design shall include defined
areas of sufficient size
in the past five years fda is looking at
facility and engineering
issues and including smoke studies why
because the regulators understand that
if we don't have adequate facility
adequate air flows
we will increase microbial contamination
in the
in the environment and in the product
lab control
should include scientifically sound
procedures
production and process control shall be
supported by written procedures
let's go to 211-113
this is going up and up on this
list every year control of micro
microbiological contamination if you
are anything like me who likes to look
at 483s and warning letters on the fda's
website
you will see that a lot of those 483s
are related to control of my
my microbial contamination in
either it's in the facility or in the
lab
personal qualifications and then
equipment cleaning and validation so
look at this the reason microbiology
related
483s have are up because they have a
myriad of sources and reasons and it
starts from facility design
let's move to this i don't know the
attendees but i
i presume that it's a mixture of of
sterile and non-steroidal manufacturers
sterile it is very clear
all microorganisms are objectionable but
when it comes to non-steroidal
it is a dilemma we all follow usp1111
those are minimum requirements
i want people to understand micro
microbes adapt we think fast
they adapt fast and hence
more and more microbes are now
becoming objectionable just a quick
story in 70s
aspergillus aspergillosis was a lung
disease of the pigeons
today 50 percent of immunocompromised
people die of aspergillus related
pneumonia mainly fumigatus
so do you think we should appear
yeah i mean the usp doesn't tell you to
test for aspergillus
you have to keep abreast with the
emerging
and the re-emerging infections you have
to understand
pathogenicity virulence virulence
factors
infectivity and effective dose
to control contamination in your product
and if you want to control contamination
in your product
you have to control contamination in
your environment
so usp one one one one is minimum
requirements but there is
a fine line there it says is the
sponsor's responsibility to look
at what and what organisms are
objectionable
in their product right now as a
microbiologist
or even a manufacturing professional in
the industry
you don't know each and every patient
you have to understand what
is predominant in terms of infections
and it
needs a lot of research you know i have
trained
my group in doing pathogen specific
assessments for this very reason
because i have the medical background
clinical background and pharmaceutical
and mycology background there are much
more
i have a book chapter in a pda book on
objectionable microorganisms you can
always
uh read it there
since we are talk we are presenting
through lab roots
i said i'm going to talk about lab
issues first lab design and operation
can that be validated rarely validated
you know in the far
east they will have controlled labs we
don't
risk is moderate to major areas dirty
areas and clean
areas are not segregated labs should
have segregation of
very clean operations very dirty
operations screen operations
and dirty operations just to tell you
and i don't read slides because i go on
tangents
the dirtiest operation in your lab is
making media
and if you are making media especially
if you are a contract lab
your media media room has to be
negatively pressured and tightly
controlled
because otherwise you will get failures
including sterility test failures
with gram positive cocci i mean grams
positive rods we are which are abundant
in dried media
media management if you look at 483s
there are
multiple 483s related to media
drive media right
wet media people talk about dry media
nobody talks about west media
cracked media you cannot do
this media look at media during your
investigation
you should have a very solid procedure
how you're going to inspect incoming
media
how you're going to release your in
coming media
will you do sterility test on the media
uh what percent of the media you will
use for sterility test
why am i harping on this whatever
i am teaching i have already made
mistakes uh
on uh in the clinical labs we used to do
uh make thousands and thousands of
plates first we used to pour and and you
know you can see that i'm pretty antique
right
if i'm telling you i did my phd in mid
70s
we used to get bales of like bales of
hay
agar was like bales of hay cut it up put
two percent
make our media then we a little bit
we advanced when i was in israel and we
used to get powdered media
but i have made all these mistakes you
can take a media
you can pour the media and you can
invert it before it looks dry
you invert it and all the media runs to
the edges and
bacillus and mold will start growing and
you will have false positive results
i have investigated tons of false
positive results
and stopped people from companies from
throwing away
valuable product because media was not
managed
growth promotion everybody knows about
growth promotion
but contamination on controls
and less or no recovery environmental
monitoring drawing of media moisture
high content
ready to use media and gpt are important
water sampling neutralizers of added
agents and systems
you have to make sure otherwise you will
get clean water and dirty product you
don't want that
uncountable colonies because of hoses
containers techniques
sterility testing is is the most
sacred test i'd say aseptic practices
are very
important don't think that if you have
an isolator you
are you are all good no isolators have
their own issues and
i can talk on barrier system flaws and
integration for another two hours
gpt sometimes was done uh
done simon simultaneously not a good
idea poor gowning practices and i'm
going to address counting
no segregation of fertility test area
you're doing sterility test in the same
little lab and you know we get a match
microbiologist get a matchbox for uh for
uh
for a lab not good idea airflows you
have to evaluate airflows in your
sterility suite you cannot have air
flowing over the personnel
onto the product if you are
doing a sterility test in a bsc
and isolators are not perfect you need
to have unidirectional
flows airflow visualization is a tool
that is under utilized by us
isolated design decontamination cycle is
very important
and sanitization is should be adequate
you cannot use sporicidal agents because
there are at least 10 480 trees
where companies are caught for sporocyte
agents
uh using sporocyte agents to sanitize or
disinfect sterility samples
endotoxin again where you are doing it
controls are
uh adequate gas sampling
please look at for uh annex one for the
first time we are talking about
anaerobic monitoring
evaluate your gases see which glasses
will promote
anaerobes and please monitor anaerobes
especially for gases that you're using
to to purge
culture dilutions many people
you must have seen it firsthand
vortexing
is very important you are vortexing
in proper handling in proper vortexing
dilution errors and of course storage
conditions
organisms die the gram the vegetative
organisms die
faster spores keep on living for a long
time
bio burden test uncountable colonies
improper storage improper dilution
and your filter you have
you have if you were from my days
you would be grateful that we have so
many technologies
we have beautiful filtration systems you
know
and the manifolds we forget to ice
we sterilize the manifold we forget to
empty the uh the drain the carboy
we forget to check the filters
or we will use different types of
filters for the same test and get
different results
those things should be avoided fire
burden tests by poor plate
hot media you don't cook your organisms
right improper mixing then you get
clumps and you cannot
you cannot count and submerge colonies
and test for specified organisms
improper enrichment
insufficient incubation times and
atypical colonies not identified
anti-microbial efficacy testing
improper culture passage culture
concentration
improper mixing and incorrect storage of
inoculated
containers again anti-microbial efficacy
test is a very involved test
takes a long time every step has to be
scrutinized incorrect ph and proper
inoculation
inoculation development not done
improper standard storage and dilution
errors
and incubation
we wait for five days or seven days for
mold
one single colony can form a whole mat
and we call it tntc that is wrong
mold spreads very fast you have to start
reading at day three
if you know that you are going to get
bacillus and especially
the ones the swarming ones like micro
mycoiders or like uniforms
you have to change your reading strategy
and incubation strategy
so as i told you you have to segregate
very clean operation sterility test
media field testing
cell culture expansion of cells other
clean operations is water testing in
process testing product testing
endotoxin testing
dirty environmental monitoring growth
promotion ids
gi studies testing bis and microbial
identification
and very dirty is weighing in
preparation of
microbiological media always and in
a negatively pressured hurt powder hood
or a negatively pressured room i want
you to explain
to explain something here
what happens this is a
las right horizontal
flow las do not belong to
microbiology lab why so
if you have one lf here and one laf what
happens
first the air comes this way it can
bounce off go on to the product it can
pass through take the contamination into
the next
next bsc or across
bse across or laf across we have seen a
lot of issues related to this they
you get false positives because you're
using lafs
equipment cleaning is very critical
we spend so much time in cleaning
cleaning equipment in the
in the facility but equipment cleaning
is very important what we clean
and how we how we manage our equipment
you know that water bots are the
biggest source of contamination they
form biofilms
and what happens you are going to
place your tubes or whatever test tubes
right
you you have solid media and test tubes
you
uh heat it up make it a liquefy it and
then you wait till it's 45 degrees
and you put it in a water bath if your
water bath
has biofilms you will
carry it to the test area and you will
contaminate
aseptic techniques are very very
important
sample sample transport very critical
your autoclaves have to be properly
validated
all these things are very important in
the lan
and the most important is your incubator
and refrigerator cleaning
lab roots has given me only one hour
this is a one day session
but i'm very grateful that i can share
my experiences
with you because of lab roots platform
incubator and refrigerator cleaning
is very important i want you to
understand
incubators and refrigerators create
grounds for microbial
growth especially mold growth a lot of
investigation small investigations for
product
failures are due not true product
failures
but because there is no good program for
incubator or refrigerator cleaning small
growth is
very very prevalent
i don't like this i'm going to go this
way
yep i talked to you about uh
about media right this is your battery
mat this is a simple petri mat
empty plates go in they get poured
at the end i mean this the tubing is
connected to your flask
end of the tubing what happens it's
pulling air you get
bubbles pits and all that now you have
fill plates you remove them you make
them stand
and then remember manufacturers
are firm media they have huge quantities
and the people working there on on
in this operation may not be
microbiologists right
or maybe college students sometimes they
don't know they don't have the
experience to see you know what
you have to validate every media
when it gets totally dry then you invert
it so if you invert it early what
happens the media
starts seeping into the lid and now you
are you know you have an incubator i
told you it's uh
it's a great source of mold the mold
falls here
mold is more tile it comes here and you
have
colony and you say oops i got a product
savior
you know mold and glue are great friends
did you know that
this is a no-no tapes are a no-no
if there is moisture this is what will
happen you cannot count colonies
your media control or quality control of
media
incoming microbiological media should
test for all this and
you do not release any media
that you feel has agar in the lid
or discoloration or bubbles or dried or
cla
cracked or sloped all this
makes a difference in the far east
uh they will pour very little media
because it's good for business for the
media business
before you know it is cracked it's dried
it doesn't grow
anything and everything passes you don't
want to
see that let's look at
this 483 observation
your firm failed to conduct
investigations related to all mold
recoveries
why am i talking mold mold is the least
understood and now there is a lot of
focus on the mold
i see it from the amount of invitations
i
get to speak on mold
this list includes all types of
mode you cannot investigate a mole
contamination
unless you know the actual id
actually i've been teaching hands-on
fungal ids for
over quarter century why
because in 1977
i was in on the evaluation committee of
the ams system i know many of you
weren't even
born or you were very young mcdonnell
douglas
made the first automated id system for
nasa
biomaria wanted to buy the id system so
biomario choose
11 prominent clinical labs in the world
our lab in israel of kaplan hospital
was chosen because my boss
was an amazing microbiologist he was a
tough tough tough boss i'm i'm a good
microbiologist
only thanks to him and also my phd
advisors
advisor dr tirumala char who is was a
prominent mycologist and madame de
berzack
of pasture institute of france who
guided me throughout my
thesis on microbial insecticides that's
what i worked on
this list include all types of mold
and i want you to understand unless you
know the mold
you will not know the source for example
aspergillus any aspergillus of
penicillium is called
what it's called a sugar fungus little
food
little moisture it will grow on the
other hand ketomium or curvularia or
alternaria actually come from
your palettes your cardboard uh your
paper
so unless you know the actual id you
will never be able to control them all
or remove it that is why why id is very
important
so going back to the 1977 when i was
evaluating ams system for
biomario i knew then
that people are going to take id systems
these
tin boxes as gods
whatever the tin box says yes sir
no we have to understand
if i we are choosing the right system we
are choosing the right lab
and if we are getting the right id
because if you don't get the right id
you
are we are going to go on a while
whose chase your whole investigation
your whole investigation is not
a worth the effort this is another one
which i want you to read through you
will have these slides
what causes no i should go to this
this is very critical how do you choose
your id system or how do you choose the
id's
id contract lab taxonomy is very
important taxonomy is
changing new organisms are being found
new organism
organisms are being renamed and for
fungus
it is always taxonomy has always been a
mess
and now it is even a bigger mess and
this is something
which will take me an hour to explain
but i want you to
understand not all fungi are the same
and fun joy are very very smart
i tell my students you should have a
gratitude prayer for fungi every morning
because if not for fungi we will not
have our bread and we will not have our
steaks
i don't eat steak by the way fungi break
down the fallen trees into simple sugars
other bacteria come in
break it down further make it into soil
and that is why we have so many
organisms in the soil
your id system should be a you have to
see if there is presence or
absence can it identify correctly
and how was the library created if the
library is very localized to your
company you will not have you will have
a lot of failed ids
if the contract lab has only national
database or only from pharmaceutical and
clinical
you will get a lot of wrong ideas or or
unidentified
isomets but if your id supplier
has an international database with
clinical agricultural
hospital pharmaceutical
from throughout the world if they're
doing a lot of ids that is where you
have to go
polyphasic approach is very important i
like to see a picture
id systems are great they're still not
perfect
trust me i'm an old school
microbiologist
and the contractor has to keep your
your uh taxonomy changes current
let's look at what creates contamination
biotic factors what is biotic
presence of that organism what is a
biotic
what are we feeding it so that it will
grow
biotic factors are those brought by foot
traffic wheel traffic we know that
on equipments and on parts right it's
the material flows personal flows
air flows are not good deficient air
material personal and waste flows
filtration failures and in gases
what are the abiotic factors where are
we feeding these
organisms they will come in there is no
sterile clean room there is no storage
land
growth in refrigerators and incubation
uh
incubators more growth in walls after
leak
if you have a leak consider it as a fire
in your facility has to be addressed all
the
all the areas where mold remember we
have
a gypsum board right what is gypsum
board sawdust
glue and cement mold has already come
with disorders because
it's coming from the trees it eats
it eats glue and it eats cement so
you have already all it needs is water
you give it water
it will spread in cold rooms
contaminating containers cold rooms are
very critical
i have seen fungal chandeliers in cold
rooms and i've seen
sample labels with beautiful designs
made by mold growing on the paper labels
and the glue
agar media and materials old gaskets
mineral oil there are many sources when
you
when you look at contamination right
control
you have to look at the abiotic factors
you are providing
so what do we need we monitor
why do we monitor to evaluate
environmental controls
facility condition personal behavior
gowning procedures aseptic techniques
risk to product and mainly patient
safety this one picture tells the whole
story
i i cannot see the picture here which is
very sad
i might switch to this mode for a moment
no
anyway i'm sure you can see the picture
over here
this here it showed up it was a little
slow to load
what is happening here this is related
to environmental monitoring
look at this rab's design this is
an open passive wrap it doesn't have its
own
peppa filter there it is under the hepa
under the room hepa filter laf
there is opening here the glove
ports are on two side of the door and
this
operator and always there is a door
there is a small opening this
operator is literally breathing into the
lab
where is the environmental monitoring
here
this is not a good idea
what is happening air is coming the
inlet
is here i told you it is a hepa filter
there's a
here diffuser diffuser is so that
it covers the gaps but you have opening
so from the person it's going from here
it's growing from here and majority of
the air is
going away into the inlet so this grade
b
environment is really even if there is a
hepa filter here
it is not getting clean air very
important
let me explain this better to you look
at this
this is actually active wraps means it
has its own hepa supply
supply but look at the
inlet it should be up here it should
come
directly from above they are the
inlet the air is being sucked from the
grade b
hepa hepa filter that means the grade b
room is starved of clean air
but it's even worse
this is a a a a depiction of a smoke
study we performed and
you know we do a lot of smoke studies we
see this
everywhere so you see it's
unidirectional over the product
it goes out through this outlet but big
only a small part is going into the
grade b
return majority because this suction is
so much stronger
majority is going over the operator
where into the inlet
and then what happens
this is he opens the door to make some
adjustments
he's already contaminated above remember
he's already contaminated here
he or she the suction
is so great that all the air coming from
this hepa filter
is going to the inlet of the wraps
it should be unidirectional and under a
non-unidirectional airflow this
contaminated operator
will be doing some interventions
not a good idea we say bses
you can put a bsc anywhere it's magic
it's not it all is related to
integration
you see that clean room and barrier
system
integration this is what a good smoke
study shows you
and you can have good contamination
control what is happening here there's a
lot of turbulence
you don't want that turbulence
smoke studies there are more
and more more and more
483s related to smoke studies most of
the people
think oh it's such a good test it's such
a simple test
we will call a certification company get
it done
if you look at uh annex one
it is mentioned that smoke studies
should be done during qualification
you should do in situ air pattern
analysis be
before media fields you should do smoke
studies to establish risk-based
monitoring sites
but you should also do smoke studies to
train your operators
in aseptic operations
very important you have some major
issues if your smoke study is not good
what is important
is the smoke should be buoyant it should
faithfully follow the air
if you have heavy smoke it will fall it
may make
even a grady room like a grade a room
or a iso 5 room this is very critical
this is a nice example
if you have an laf and this is a really
good
really good example where a company
making media had media fill failures
so this was their filling line and they
had an laf here
and it was blowing directly on through
the filling line
beyond that they had a major issue
this is everywhere we see if you have
hepa filters
and you have gaps between hepa filters
do you think you can clean these
never what happens if you have a filling
you are open open product under this
this is where smoke study shows you
where the turbulence is
and you will not have open product where
there is turbulence
it's very important to understand
personnel and material flows
doesn't have to be fancy cat drawing it
can be a hand
drawn diagram understand where personal
material waste flow
intercept and what are the contamination
challenges there this is another one
and this is related to equipment this
inappropriate system design
fosters development of biofilms
i am telling you biofilms are still
in their baby stage we actually
do smoke study to under understand
why you get uh biofilms and
reactors bioreactors or in ufdf
and there are case studies where we have
seen that the
hmi exhaust was spewing dirty air
directly on the aseptic connection
it's understand it is very important to
understand
your equipment and how contamination can
be formed in the equipment this is a
laboratory error
following this is so
so prominent in 483s
you sterility test failure we stopped at
a lab investigation we don't even do a
thorough investigation
any lab investigation has to be
thorough only if it is a not a lab
related issues you have to start a
manufacturing investigation and the
facilities
really go we go to facilities and
majority of the issues come from
facilities especially
when it is human bone contamination uh
sometimes it's soil borne but a lot of
times human born
you know a lot of data integrity issues
in em happen where in the barrier
systems in the wraps
open close wraps and bscs and
that picture that comes next i'm going
to show you
what are the reasons deficient barrier
system design and integration
lack of sterility of equipment
deficiencies and aseptic
practices non-juris unidirectional
airflows deviant air
dead error eddy currents inadequate gown
choices
count choice and ground management come
compounded by bad airflows ergonomics
ergonomics is uh it's getting the
regulator's attention these days
i want you to look at this
this is from a single smoke study
the air is flowing this way it has to be
unidirectional this is a filling line
right
what is what you're seeing is one
light one hepa filter
gap in between and this operator the air
is flowing on
from the operator over to the open
product
a good smoke study can help you with
this
so that you know where the issues are
not issues
can all issues can be remediated but at
least you can do risk based monitoring
account gown choice and management
is least understood in our industry
look at this there are tons of these
observations worn gowns fraying cups
and you have seen recalls with particles
in it
fibers in it it all comes from gown
gowns ground choice tarts
in the beginning what happens
who chooses our gowns purchasing
what is their goal least money
longest contract doesn't work
gowns have to be right size
right material porosity abrasive
resistance and most important shedding
ground laundries if you're using laundry
gowns
you have to limit the number of
laundries
and how is it done using a hemke drum
test
the contract the laundry gown supplier
has to tell you
at which laundry cycle will it start
generating a lot of particles that's
where you have to stop
also laundry you cannot use an ionic or
cationic have to be known an
ionic detergent you cannot iron your
gowns you cannot
dry them beyond 60 degrees you will fray
gowns
and you will see so you will compound
the issues if your airflows are not good
your barrier is not um
optimal and your gowns are not optimal
what do you
get contamination galore
wrong gowning sequence stacky mats not
used correctly tachymets
there are options polymeric flooring
stepping on
tacky mats after wearing shoe covers not
a great idea
hanging gowns in correctly right
and gone stored in cardboard boxes
sometimes i see dedicated and
non-dedicated shoes in the same kabil
very important to manage your gowns
cleaning
disinfection is not magic
we use phenolic compounds uh quaternary
ammonium compounds
which kill vegetative bacteria do not
kill spores
they do have fungicidal label claim
but they kill the weak fungi
not the strong fungi weak fungi are the
deuteromycota where the spores are
formed outside
they are very weak they are very tiny
esco mycota has two layers of protection
what happens disinfectant
cannot go through but we cannot blame
the disinfectant manufacturers
because they have to follow aoac testing
which is recommended by
epa and which tells you to test with the
weak organisms
we use bacillus settlers whereas
bacillus series is hard to go
so it's very very important that
understand the disinfectant
activity is it a sporicidal not
sporicidal
sometimes i go to companies and they use
decon clean
it's not even a disinfectant it is
residue stripper
you have to know the disinfectant
activity before you even
start your developing your uh program it
has to be science-based
optimal dilution you cannot increase or
decrease the dilution if you decrease
the
solution you get less kill if you
increase the dilution what do you get
compromise facility cracking walls paint
chipping off
material compatibility is very very
critical
nobody looks at this adequacy of the
decent all this and then you have to
know your data your baseline
organisms so you can have a good program
and then your trend reports should
dictate
whether you're going to change your
cleaning program or not training
a changer cleaning program i am telling
you disinfectant manufacturers have all
this information
that is your what they have tested with
if they have tested for more organisms
than aoac has suggested
your material compatibility data use
dilution
the 10 minute contact time is not the
absolute contact time
the 10 minute contact time is the
minimum contact time
which the manufacturer put it when they
test if all the
tubes don't grow at 10 minutes they put
10 minutes does that mean at 15 minutes
that
the organism they are testing will
resurrect and come back to life
absolutely not you don't kill the
disinfectant
in its frequency some people will apply
the disinfectant and what will they do
remove it what have you done leave it
disinfectant work for six to seven
hours depending upon the nature of the
surface
i only at microwave we do a study to
prove this
and diffuse diffuse this 10 minute
contact time
fluff it is totally fluff and it's going
everywhere and people talk about oh my
supplies can give you 10 minute car
what is 10 minute contact time meat wet
time
dry time the more you wet your facility
the more contamination you have
especially walls and mold so this has to
be addressed
very clearly uh this is a very important
so this is a tough to kill mold i told
you that the disinfectants are tested
with easy to kill mold they got this
mold in the filling line
uh they could not kill with one is 200
dilution of the
disinfectant so the director of
microbiology decided he's going to look
he's going to use one is 250 dilution
never he didn't even know that
compatibility is an issue
what happened they had cracked walls
they were painting the walls every two
months
they were afraid of pa chemistry
parasitic absolute chemistry
they tell you know when i went to the
company i said
it's your fault it's not the
disinfectant manufacturer's fault
they you should ask for material
compatibility you should know everything
and then they were afraid of using poor
acetic acid chemistry
whereas parasitic acid chemistries are
the ones that zap
most spores right this was the
opposite case the operators did not like
the smell
so what did they decide they want to
dilute the poor acetic acid chemistry
and what happens next
they have contamination
next is fogging everybody's fogging
these days they think they can
get rid of microorganisms and covered
and
everything oh fogging [ __ ] companies
are having a lot of fun fogging
is a science there's a lot of things you
have to know
number one the fog size is has to be
small
otherwise it will not be buoyant it will
not stay in the air
the heavier the fog the it will fall
down it will not go into nooks and
crannies
you should know the capacity of the
fogger how many square feet it can cover
so you can't get a single fogger and fog
a thousand square foot clean room the
the nozzle directions and
the instructions that a fogging company
gives a supplier gives you
the this it's itself is a science
and you have to follow this is something
i'm going to end with
i went two minutes or three minutes over
this was a tissue bank they were failing
almost every tissue product
that they were making skin grafts bone
grafts whatever
what was happening they were cleaning
their bses with
phenolic compounds phenolics leave
residues
correct look at the grid
full of residue what is the job of this
grill
if any air comes in it removes it goes
in it doesn't allow
what was happening here the air was
coming
in bouncing off this this block grills
and and jumping off to the
product so it was people
contamination it was room contamination
and they did not understand this
infection
now i am i hope this was helpful
um you have my contact information if we
cannot uh uh
answer all the questions but i am ready
to answer all the questions
alexis
wonderful thank you ziva for that
informative presentation so we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started ziva we've got some
great questions that have come in during
your
um during your presentation let's take a
look
and see which one we want to start off
with
so i will go i i'm looking at question
number three here
that is not me to answer that is a
regulatory question
i am a contamination control expert uh
the question number four is
sterilization is one of the most
expensive stages of bioprocess
we are making products for human use
and and companies make money on this
product
i understand that it is an expensive but
it is one of the most
critical process and we cannot take
shortcuts
can i continue alexis yeah absolutely
there we've got we still got a couple
more questions in so
which one works works for being next
yes so i'm looking at these questions
some of the questions are very vague and
i think
i think that these all water related
questions should be taken offline
because i think they are a continuation
of one another
sure absolutely so it looks like number
six which is frequency for the whole
time study of water used in
manufacturing of drugs and how long does
it take for microbes to grow on water
we'd be happy to answer those offline um
provided yes these are very involved
questions
for herbal products what precaution
could be used to avoid contamination
herbal products are very
there's so much contamination comes from
the
it comes from uh uh from herbal products
i can take this offline because we have
done
a lot of work in herbal products and
things have
changed i know you have to look at the
uh i don't remember the monographs and
oh no they're general chapters
there's a lot more than just using the
usp
general chapters there are other
guidances we can take this
offline and i will be more than happy to
guide this person
for herbal products how often would you
suggest to clean the incubators
refrigerators or watermark
twice a week depending upon the use
once a week at a minimum this is
question 12
i've answered there was another here
what is a good source for smoke
test material uh we can take this
offline because i want people to
understand
the smoke test materials the pros and
cons of every
smoke test material
yes weekly is minimum for water baths
and all
and also drain the water baths okay
always drain
wipe it down with a sporocycle agent and
then ipa
change the tubing and autoclave the
tubing that tubing
some i've seen real gross tubing with
slime and biofilm in it so
uh take care of this tubing too uh how
you suggest about overall design in
order
to avoid overall design overall design
depends upon the product right
uh it is very you cannot
say okay you know i'm going to make a
nasal product i have a space in my
warehouse i'm going to put a modular
clean room you will have contamination
so this is again an offline question i'm
ready to discuss
a few design criteria but it all depends
upon this
all depends upon what kind of product
that you
use uh you're making so the design
criteria
really really will be dictated by the
product
and the risk to patient
what about the question what about
question number 21 of how often the
smokes
how often should the smoke study be
performed
okay smoke studies are are performed
uh once during qualification
if you're an aseptic manufacturer you
have to do in-situ air pattern analysis
that is both the static and the dynamic
simulating all your interventions
and according to uh annex one
you have to use it you use these smoke
studies to establish your um
risk-based environmental monitoring site
and you have to use smoke studies
for training your operators so they know
that
that their their interventions are such
that the outer
outer the air from grade b
or less control area is not flowing over
the operator and they also understand
how they manipulate are they posing a
risk to product
normally you're supposed to do uh once
in two years
but remember it is very good to do it
as a part of uh as a part
of your qualification and then at least
institute pattern analysis
use it for your em smoke studies are
in the past five years there are more uh
more
483s related to smoke studies than we
have seen
at least i've seen in my whole career i
can talk more about it
it's also depending upon what risk you
have what kind of facility you have
and i would like to talk to this person
about
some of the do's and don'ts in smoke
studies
because people are getting into trouble
for that
the 15 looks a very good one
yeah so uh question 15 is uh thank you
for your helpful presentation
based on your experience what type of
disinfect
disinfectants is better to eliminate the
mold and fungi in the labs
okay let me explain something to you i
explained it very briefly that not all
disinfectants
uh can kill everything right so
you should have note you should have a
general purpose disinfectant with a
surfactant in it what is the surfactant
so
your phenolics and your quaternary
ammonium compounds do that job
soap means it breaks surface tension so
you
you are disinfecting getting rid of the
vegetative bacteria phenolics and quartz
but you're also cleaning because there
is soap
as a sporicidal agent you can use
bleach or parasitic acid chemistries
right but bleach is very finicky and
i want to make i want to tell you this
if you have a bleach container and keep
it open the kill depends upon
available chlorine and the available
chlorine drops very fast
then you have your sporacitic acid
chemistries
now prosthetic and i love parasitic acid
chemistries i know people
don't like the vinegary smell but what
is wrong in being a
plastic pickle jar it's not that bad you
can use respirators
osha recommends respirators
but one thing i want you to remember
nothing kills all mold nothing
because the testing has been performed
with
very weak mold detromycota
aspergillus if you get ketomium the case
study i said
it will not kill so don't
consider disinfection as the only
contamination control
strategy preventive contamination
prevent the contamination coming
in and then remediate what has already
gotten
i hope i made it clear
that was great thank you ziva it looks
like we probably have time for
one more one more question
you choose alexis i'll leave it up to
you
okay let's look for um let's
look for one more question i like the
seventeen
what is sampling test works for
environmental for production errors and
special contact
with uh
you are
it should be a mix of
particle and this is a a whole new
subject
people miss the science behind particle
monitoring
a lot of compounding pharmacies and it
looks like this is a compounding
pharmacy
put in put in continuous monitoring
systems
but don't know how to interpret the data
you have to have
another thing i don't like taking
portable counters into the
lafs and most compounding pharmacies
have
lax and it is an uphill battle for us at
microwave telling compounding pharmacies
please use biological safety cabinets
you have better contamination control
but then the consultants in the
compounding pharmacy area will tell them
laf
so never bring in equipment inside that
is why you have remote sampling
you have pre-hard-wired sampling probes
right you should know how so continuous
sampling
of non-viable particle during your
compounding
continuous sampling of viable particles
by using sacrifice and uh
[Music]
and active air sampling in the
surrounding areas that is the minimum
you should do
for a compounding pharmacy and
of course personnel monitoring after
every every time the operator comes out
of the laf
he has to do fips or gloves
or gowns whatever you choose i hope that
was helpful
perfect thank you so much siva um we
really appreciate your outstanding
outstanding presentation along with
answering all of those questions
do you have any final comments for our
audience
uh i would like them to go through this
really
try to study or i have hit the important
points
and and again i i can
talk to you as long as you don't make it
in one hour
conversation 10 minutes conversation
if you have doubts my goal is to people
realize
that we can avoid contamination up front
instead of
having contaminated product harming the
company of course it harms
the income right it's it's a big cost
if you fail product but also keeping the
patients safe
and my my email is here and you can
go through alexis or or alexis would you
prefer that they
directly contact me or through you it's
up to you
that's absolutely fine you can actually
during the on-demand period you still
can't post questions and they will be
answered um
and sent over to ziva um even after
today's live broadcast
so um before we go i would like to thank
the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
as a reminder questions we did not have
time for today and
you can still submit them during the
on-demand period they'll be addressed by
ziva
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank ziva
for her time today and her important
research
we'd also like to thank labberts and our
sponsor sartorius for underwriting
today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you so much for
joining us
stay safe stay healthy and until next
time
bye bye everyone